we are pleased to have on the phone line
a general manager who was right in the
thick of things as all of them were but
this GM in particular because he was uh
I guess you know I've been doing this
draft a long time I've never really seen
somebody take the approach of the best
jail and available for the first two
picks in his draft he's a general
manager of the Eagles Howard Roseman how
are you how we I'm good I didn't realize
that third round pick that was his
middle name well it's just the first it
looks like you want the best available
you know there's not many rosemond's
either as we go one is to say fact
that's to say to me everything I'd say
them ready to play go back so let's uh
let's get into it right here I love that
let's get into it 21st overall you had
your choice of the guy you took John
Riegert also Justin Jefferson Brandon I
you qui did you take the the young man
out of TCU of 21st overall what you like
about him man this was a heck of a
receiver draft everybody knew that and
it was like going to Dunkin Donuts and
sitting there with your family and
picking out that your favorite doughnut
you know you really couldn't go wrong
with the amount of talent that they had
and so when we look at this we try to do
things that fit our team that's it what
we have what we need and of course you
know the evaluation of the player and
all those guys you named we had a lot of
love for those guys to their hack of
players they're really good players but
you know jaylen when we when we thought
about jaylen and what he could add to
our office what his skill set is you
know this is an explosive guy who can
separate on the outside vertically he
can run those go routes those post route
he's good on those jet sweeps he's good
in the backfield he's a returner so he's
really good with the ball in his hands
he's explosive you know when you look at
his testing we thought he played a lot
faster than the 447 and then you see you
know his unbelievable vertical and broad
and we have something that we know his
dad you know he played for us Monta and
so we knew the kid really well and when
we think about what a guy like this can
do when you have him
on the outside and obviously we got the
Shawn and probably the you know one of
the best speed receivers in history the
NFL and learning from him and our
intermediate targets our tight end room
which we think may be the best in the
NFL and Zach and Dallas and and you know
we have a Sean and JJ who drafted last
year at Mile Sanders and just the way
our quarterback likes to play and and
you could see it going back and watching
our tape when he's throwing the ball
down the field and then it just opens up
everything else and I remember going
back about two weeks ago and we watching
some of our season and watching our
first game against the Redskins and
there was one play where D Jack was
streaking down the sideline and our saw
receiving oh my god were streaking down
the middle of the field and the thing
that was most apparent to me was a Kurtz
was standing in the middle of field wide
open with his hands raised
Carson's on touchdown but some of those
things you know they they can just
really open up the field and you know I
learned under coach Reid and you've seen
what he's done with the target he's got
it at Kansas City yeah no doubt about
that everyone wants to obviously
replicate that as best as possible with
speed but when did Rhaegar have you did
he have you at hello like was it the
combine was it a piece of tape in
particular what was it well it was funny
because you know we really start the
process right after the draft and in May
and in May I knew there was a chance
that this was going to be loaded you
always hear kind of we always try to
look a year out and see the strengths of
the draft a year out and we knew was
going to be really strong receiver draft
so I started watching them and when you
look at his 18 taboos phenomenal you
know he's a 19 year old true sophomore
and it was phenomenal
so he really got on the radar of May
last year and then just following him
and and seeing some of the plays that he
made that we're just really fun to watch
and you know we got Pro Bowl quarterback
so I think a real benefit from that as
well yes you do have a Pro Bowl
quarterback you also know you just walk
me into an alley I mean you know you
just base that's an open door hello
hello Jim look I love its treatment
I love jaylen Hertz okay I love him we
had him on the show about 10 days ago I
just love his story I love everything
about him though
however are out there wondering why you
would take him when you given a
gajillion dollars and I think that is
the exact amount of money that you have
given or report towards carson wentz why
why take jaylen Hertz where you did
Howie you know rich my job is to do
everything I can to make Carson one
successful yes we have so much invested
in them and we've shown him with our
actions how we feel about him whether
it's better trading up all those picks
well it's you know giving him the
contract extension and I think we've
done that you know we we've got a good
group of skilled position guys our
offensive line is good we helped him by
getting guys like Hargrave and slay and
Roby and Reese on and our safeties and
free agency that all helps them building
a good team it helps them but my job is
to ensure that our team and our on our
organization were protected and that all
these guys you know our coaches work all
these hours our players starting today
with the virtuosity agent program put in
so much time into the building our staff
is there all the time I got to make sure
I'm doing everything I can that we can
have success and we're a product of our
experiences and I've been in Philly for
a long time and you know I saw in 2002
AJ Feeley went for and - and we got
home-field advantage throughout the
playoffs I saw that you know Donovan
McNabb got knocked out of a championship
game and we went to our backup
quarterback I saw in 2005 Donovan went
down we went 5 and 11 the next year we
got Jeff Garcia we won the division we
saw we won with backups we won the
division with Vick and Nick as backups
and obviously you know over the last few
years you know like Carson leading us to
that home-field advantage in 2017 and
Nick's finishing it off so you know I
feel like just watching what goes on
around the league and seeing you know
even see last year a couple of teams
lost their starting quarterback and they
struggled they struggled a lot and I
just got to make sure that we have an
opportunity to be successful with our
depth
we played eight offensive linemen last
year you know this is a depth league to
win a Super Bowl
right now minimum you got to play 19
games
in the coming years you'll have a
17-game so that'll be 20 that's a lot of
games that's a lot of depth so I say
that and then it's got to be the right
player and you know I think what what's
really sad for me is that Jalen Hertz is
getting lost in this I can get it you
know you people can question my sanity
and whether it was the right thing to do
right resource to spend you know I
obviously don't agree with it that's why
we took the second-round pick but this
kid is a heck of a player he's a heck of
a person he's a huge asset to any team
we're lucky to have him and I just feel
bad that you know people don't
understand how good he is and how good
of a teammate he is well I mean he said
that any team that gets him is gonna be
getting a dog and we in terms of a
teammate I mean you saw what he did at
Oklahoma last year he he goes to a team
like Oklahoma and says he wanted to help
you know he didn't use the word culture
change but he did want to bring certain
sense of attitude to the program that he
didn't think might have been there I
mean like and he you can buy it from him
you don't think like there's anything
egotistical about him he is as dynamite
as they come in anybody who might not
understand that just needs to google his
name and to us right at the same time
and you could you could learn all of
that but all that said how are you gonna
use him I mean do you plan on on on even
having a package or to taste some he'll
type stuff like is that in the cards
Holly you know I can't give you the
answers to the test is my job to find
out the answers though I know I can't do
that you know but obviously we have a
tremendous coaching staff led by a
tremendous head coach and you know it's
our job to get them at any point makers
at the disposal but you know listen
Carson Wentz is a Pro Bowl quarterback
we can win a Super Bowl with him as our
starting quarterback and you know we
just kind of went through all right if
we it's the guys that we had on the
board if we took this position or that
position can we find them
and it's always been since coach
Peterson came here since I came back in
2016 you know we said we were gonna have
a vision and values and it was going to
start with being strong at the
quarterback position and I know when you
know we gave Sam that money
chased that money and then trade it up
for fur Carson there's a lot of the same
conversation and I just this is who we
are
you know we want to have a strong room I
said something late on Friday night that
the media's you know give me a little
hard time for so I'm not going to say
that we just want a strong room and we
want him strong team we want to we want
to have strong depth at every area
especially the areas we think are really
important to win the football games
international poly that's the longest
yes I've ever gotten Howie that's the
longest yes I've ever gotten was the
question I love talking to you man this
is so much fun by the way amazing job
with the draft Athan man that was very
very cool I appreciate that
well I mean being part of raising money
and let alone a hundred million bucks
for Kovac 19 relief I mean that really
was amazing and I do I gotta be honest
with you I feel for Myles Sanders a
little bit he was sitting right there in
the draft a thon draft room with all of
us just as jaylen Hertz was selected
nears this poor kid in his second year
like you know everyone's just keep and
abuse on him about it like what's going
on with your quarterback you know and
and he he handled it like a pro because
we were just having her fund a lot of it
was tongue-in-cheek is you know that man
that kids I know he and he did so well
last year so but that said did you did
you call Carson I mean understand again
that that you you still picked up the
phone and gave him a heads-up that hey
we're about to take jaylen did that
happen
you know I've spoken to him earlier that
day and you know really the day before
and throughout the offseason just kind
of telling him what was going on and I
told him that depending on how the board
went that it was a possibility and and
Carson's an unbelievable team guy I mean
he wants what's best for the team now
listen I understand you know I'm sure
everyone's in there and wants what's
best for the moment you know but that's
not really our job our job is to protect
the organization protect the team for
the long term and and when you look at
that position in all the sports man it's
got to be the most important position at
all sports
yeah and I know in Deion Sanders in the
draft Athan live room was just having
fun saying how come they're the only
position on the field that can't have
competition you know like I'm a corner
but I'm not allowed to be upset if
somebody's you know being drafted at my
position as a matter of fact I'm I'm
supposed to compete with this person and
on top of it I'm supposed to tutor the
youngster you know but the quarterback
is not supposed to I mean like that well
is this and there's no competition
Carson Wentz's our quarterback I want to
be clear with that you know it's about
having a strong room it's about making
sure that all of us are having guys on
our team who can come in and play I mean
you know you look at it last year and
and you even see it when we look about
kind of first short period of time you
know you know we had an opportunity and
so much respect for Josh McCown as a
player in person but obviously you know
we're playing in a playoff game with her
backup quarterback and you look at the
Saints this past year and they go five
and over Bridgewater and the Chiefs had
mahomes go down and had to get through
three games and went two and one and got
home-field advantage so you know and how
important that is so it's just to us you
know what would you pay for that if you
had to do it and and you know someone
told me this a guy who is incredibly
successful on Wall Street and he said
you know when you hedge you pay for that
and everyone doesn't want to pay for
expensive insurance until you need it
how heroes 'men executive VP and general
manager of the Eagles here with me for a
few more minutes on the Rich Eisen show
so much made of the virtual draft Howie
and now that it's done and it seemed to
go without a hitch
did were there fewer trades in your
estimation or less activity because of
it this year do you think I would have
said that after Thursday night maybe
would have even said that after Friday
night but man Saturday picked up into
gear and I felt like it was rolling like
nothing else and the reality of it is
like we're talking to these GM's on
their phone anyway there's no difference
so I didn't think that that was a big
part of it and and you know it's
specially I know rich you've got a big
family I got a big thing
and I've never been able to share you
know I've never even watched an Eagles
game to it with my kids if people
believe that you know I don't say with
them during games I don't watch the
games with them on the road and so to be
able to experience this with them it was
special special is an experience that
none of us will ever forget yeah I know
a lot of a lot of evaluators are saying
that so and that and that the format was
also more enjoyable I guess insert for
people to watch because there seemed to
be more of a flow um would you want to
do it again then what do you think if
the we were to be in one to be there no
I know I need to I needed to be the
poster boy for giving my opinion on what
we're doing that I guess it does there
is a because again I enjoyed doing what
I did and then I was able to put my kids
to sleep like my commute was the stairs
you know what I'm saying so yeah yeah my
commute was the stairs too and again you
know I it was it was fun it was fun to
be able to kind of walk out in between
picks and it was also I think it was for
my kids to be able to see how that
worked right and to see how we're kind
of juggling everything and and kind of
appreciate why dad's not home a lot I
think that this whole kind of process
about how we're working through it it's
given us all perspective on kind of
balance work home life balance and you
know maybe maybe face time may be
guarding guarding your desk which we all
do to some levels you know I don't want
to go you know I got all these people in
here and at the same time though I miss
the people in our building
I missed the people that we work with
every day too so it's about so is it any
truth to the rumor that you drafted Sean
Bradley in the sixth round because your
kids just saw Space Jam no Jed yeah that
that that they just saw Space Jam and
they thought you should draft Sean
Bradley and that's why you did it
is that a true story yeah okay okay very
good
I got like a different spelling but I
guess it's just having another Sean
Bradley back in Philadelphia that makes
sense even though he's already there and
I know my kids for some reason you know
I
them a new poll you know my little boys
I got I got a 8 year old and a six year
old and they're like obsessed with like
looking at my new polls cuz its bo Boll
oh no thanks like I said once them I
said you got to see that and now they
watch like highlights of the new poll
YouTube's an amazing thing man it really
is hey Howie thanks to the time really
appreciate it
thanks Ravi man stay safe everyone and
look forward to keeping in touch right
back at you that's how he Roseman EVP
and GM of the Philadelphia Eagles you're
on the Rich Eisen show hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here